ces informations là c'est pas normal
qu'ils soient entre guillemets si facile
de pirater les données des labos ça fait
plusieurs années qu'on parle de cloud
souverain peut-être que toutes ces
données là elles devraient être stockées
dans un cloud sécurisé par l'état
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces fichiers avaient des informations
qui étaient pour le temps pour le coupe
ultra sensible avec certaines maladies
infectieuses notamment et ça peut avoir
des conséquences sur la capacité des
gens à trouver un assureur sur leur
réputation auprès de leur employeur dont
beaucoup beaucoup d'incidence pour la
vie privée
[Musique]
on
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on parle de crise sanitaire et au
passage on restera un certain nombre de
libertés la façon dont on contrôle passe
énormément à travers les outils
numériques les smartphones etc
il en va finalement tracer tous les tous
les déplacements des gens alors ça se
voit beaucoup dans certains pays
asiatiques
un peu moins chez nous et voilà c'est
une vraie tendance de fond et il faut
faire attention à ce que ce soit pas
quelque chose eux qui deviennent normal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]